Joining us all the way
from the United Kingdom.
Please give a warm welcome to poly Samson.
So probably,
let's start off a little bit about your
upbringing and kind of how your career
started. So tell me about that
journey to becoming a writer.
Where did you decide as a student or
the child that writing was what you were
going to pursue? Um, I,
I'd never decided, uh,
to write because I always wrote,
um,
and it wasn't until I had my own
children and some of them right.
And some of them, you know, not such ready
writers, but when I had my own children,
I said they aged about five and I think,
well,
where are all these little stories and
patterns and waiting for this eruption of
writing,
it never happened.
I then realized that it was just something
in me and it was something I'd always
done.
And so there wasn't a sort of blinding
flash where I decided to be a writer.
It was just a natural
progression. Regression. Yeah.
There's bits and pieces of your family
history that shows up in both of the
collections and the novel as well.
Kind of,
is there a particular story that inspired
you for a certain passage or you have
a rich family has all learning about
it as an amateur for the audience?
It's a great, well, um,
my family history for
those who don't know,
my parents were both refugees
into England in 1938.
My mother was six at the time,
half Chinese coming from Shanghai fleeing
the Japanese and my father who was 10
at the time, um, came from
Hamburg on the Kindertransport.
Um, I mean obviously they
didn't meet then. They had
very different journeys. My,
my father, there was a large Jewish
family that embraced him and he, you know,
went on to study and become a journalist.
My mother unfortunately ended up in an
orphanage and the age of 16 took herself
back to China to find her father.
She didn't find her father,
but she found a revolution and she joined
my mouse army and for 10 years was in
red China until eventually
she got out again. Yeah.
There's a lot there for me to draw on
and I don't directly right about their,
their histories, but it certainly
informs a lot that I do. Yeah. Um,
along that journey of writing between
Novelis, between short stories,
obviously there's a different
process that's involved, um,
mentally you need to change
the way you're going to write.
Can you tell me a little bit about that
transition between the different writing
styles, between lyrics, between
if there's major events,
kind of that drove you again in
one of these directions or there's,
when you decide I'm done with my first
novel and I want to work on short stories
and I'm going to try and lyrics, kind
of, how did that begin? States again,
I think every,
every story finds its medium.
I'm writing a short story is,
is it's almost simpler because you can
keep the whole idea in your head without
feeling like your brain is going to
explode. You know, it's, it's, it's, uh,
it's very containable. Uh, it goes
very well with having small, actually,
because you don't need
to write anything down,
but you've got this whole other secret
world and you're sort of wandering around
doing the rest of your life and kind of
writing and editing so that by the time
I write a short story,
it's like typing. Yeah,
it's at worked on it so much in my
head. But with a novel, you know,
your brain would explode if you tried to
keep a whole novel in your head in that
way so that you'd have to be
more in a way more rigorous.
You have to sit at your desk
every day and work on it.
And certainly towards the
end of writing a novel,
there's a sort of feeling of mounting
panic that you really don't want it to
leave your desk at all.
I can remember when I was writing
my first novel and you know,
the family kind of knew to leave me
alone in the later stages of it. And um,
there was a knock at the door and
it was my husband and he said,
we need to go to parents' evening.
And I said,
why do I have to go to parents' evening?
And he said,
you're a parent to that
gets a little obsessional.
And then lyric writing is different again,
because I'm not drawing
entirely on something in me.
I've got this wonderful prompt,
which is that the music comes first.
So lyric writing again,
it takes place mainly when I'm walking
much less sitting at the desk and I have,
I do one song at a time
and I have a track in my,
in my earphones and it's playing
and playing and playing. And,
and I often do that. I
think it's, you know,
often referred to as the Paul
Mccartney method, you know,
scrambled eggs was yesterday and I start
to make up something and then gradually
some sort of meaning will
emerge and yeah, so it's, it's,
it's miles on the feet for a song as well.
So even within the kindness,
I think there are entire chapters that
on their own can be a short story.
Did you find yourself picking up pieces
that you didn't include in perfect lives
or in other kind of collections you were
working on that you then incorporate it
in and change the characters or, no, not
really. I stash that you keep somewhere.
I wish. I really wish I did. I
don't, I, I don't actually, um,
the kindness started life
in a different format. Um,
I was feeling quite militant about
short stories because publishers,
certainly in the UK,
I think it's different in the u s
but in the UK there's a kind of self
fulfilling prophecy. Earl, you know,
short stories don't sell. And so I,
my last collection had been a
collection of linked short stories.
And so I thought, well, I'll take this
one stage further, I'll do a novella.
And at the end of the Novella,
my main character, Julian, um,
would have an explosion of creativity.
And within that he would write some short
stories that would show that he's come
to some sort of realization of the,
the events of his life that he
hadn't understood in the novella.
And so I did start the kindness by
writing his short stories and then very
quickly realized that however militant
type thoughts about short stories,
it was better to get the novel right and
that it needed to be a novel and things
find their form and that
demanded to be a novel. Yeah.
You mentioned about your creative process,
walking kind of you.
Where do you find that inspiration?
Is it just walking the dog outside,
taking in the air, sitting in your study?
You mentioned a few different things. Um,
well I can't sit and stare at a blank
screen because I find that really
agitating and I don't know
how anyone does that. I mean,
there are a lot of people who will say
writing is about fixing the bum to the
seat. Well, I don't really agree
with that. I think, you know,
I've got a really grateful dog.
He,
he's very keen on this idea that writing
is about doing about 10 miles walking a
day. And I think that if you walk
and you're thinking about it,
and I often do something called method
writing where I walk as my character and
whatever's happening, I see it through
my character's eyes and you know,
be quite embarrassing at times.
You know, cause you know,
my main character in the kindness
is, is a man called Julian. You know,
women are coming towards me and I'm
Julian and I'm giving them a once over and
cause I really convinced myself
that I am that character. And um,
by the time you get back to the
desk, it does, it flows. You know,
if you've put the,
if you've put the miles in on your feet
and you've really managed to think about
it and you've really got under the skin
of that character, there's no trouble.
Once you get back to this,
to this there,
I know we've talked to you right
sometimes about the inspiration.
Are there particular authors that
have influenced you a lot? Um,
a particular time period in writing,
whether it's UK literary history,
American literary history,
other parts of the world where you're
drawing short stories and fables that have
been strung together for you.
Who are those kind of, well,
my main
inspiration probably came from,
I worked in publishing in the 1980s in
the UK and I worked for a company called
Jonathan Cape,
which was the literary publisher.
And it was run by a total
genius called Tom Maschler.
And you know, I mean he invented
the Booker Prize, for example.
He published you named you
named some great authors. He,
you know, Martin Amus, IOM,
McEwen, Nadine Gordimer,
Doris Lessing, Bruce Chatwin,
Margaret Atwood, Salman Rushdie, you
know, it was just ridiculous. Our list,
you know, it can wonderful place to
work. And it meant that I read really,
really great books for my job. It
was, you know, it was heavenly.
And so I think that that
period of literature has
been very influential because
I read so much of it and nowadays I
still read a lot of my contemporaries,
but I'm having a surreal moment of
catching up with the Victorians.
And I'm loving it. Actually. It's, you
know, it's good to go back. It's good to,
to go back. There's so much
great stuff in every period.
And then poetry when, when I'm
writing fiction, I don't read fiction,
but I start every day by reading really
good poetry and different poets for
different books. I mean a perfect
lives. I read a lot of, um,
Neruda Strangely and for, um, uh,
kindness. I started with one of
my favorite poets, WB eights,
and then very quickly realized that I
really needed to get into John Milton
because I'd made Julian Milton scholar.
So I spent a year reading paradise lost,
which was not a year lost to
me. It was a wonderful year. Um,
and then another poet who I adore is a
contemporary poet called David level,
who I think he's,
I don't know how well known he is,
but he is amazing. And I, I,
I'd say that if anyone's looking for a
contemporary poet, he lives in Texas.
I think he's probably
in his eighties by now.
He has published since the early
sixties consistently not a bad word.
Flows from his pen.
Just incredible stuff.
You just mentioned paradise lost.
I think there are overt references.
There are references that
you would have had to read,
the kind of whole story together for you.
Was that the driving factor in your,
I know you mentioned you don't
organize it kind of in a web,
but how did you decide where to
weave in paradise lost her are,
did you have a Schema and outline for
you that you said these are references?
I know Zephyr, I know there's Lucifer,
he's a scholar. Yeah. It just,
it just gave me a feeling of daily
while I was writing because it's,
it's kind of secret layer in the brook
because actually I think there are very
few people who really know paradise
lost. Yeah. Here it's required reading,
I think in middle school, high school,
and then people forget about it.
And I think in England it's,
it's,
it's also required reading and I think
there's nothing like required reading to
put people off a writer. Um, and,
um, so I was lucky, you know,
I,
I have no formal education,
so I came to it on my own and it was a
joy because it takes you off into so many
areas, you know, labyrinth time
kind of footnotes if you get,
if you get the Longman edition,
which has amazing notes,
I mean the classical references,
the biblical references,
it's an education all on its own as well
as being the most extraordinary piece
of writing. Um, and so, yeah.
Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Sorry,
what's the question? I think you
answered it. And along with that,
I think at the research, I know you do a
lot of research going into your novels.
For you, this novel took a
little bit longer to write,
kind of why did it take longer this time?
It,
was it the research that
we're doing differently?
Are you researching characters
specifically or you come
up with an idea for a
plot and then decide if I researched this,
it will become a lot more concrete
and descriptive. Well, I think, um,
I think I could blame youtube for,
for some rotten,
because of course it's been a, it is
the perfect writers resource. You know,
you don't have to go and
wander around Amsterdam.
You can just go onto youtube and you can
find that that street and you can find
lovely clips of it. And it, it
really does help enormously. I mean,
another thing that youtube was early
enough for when I was writing this novel
was there's a scene and it's quite
a pivotal scene where my character,
Julian gets to see,
he has a friend who's a medical student
and he gets to see his sperm under the
microscope. And I wanted to write this
piece. I wanted to write it, you know,
I didn't want to just write
and they look like tadpoles.
I wanted to kind of get something more
out of the scene because it's such an
important scene. And so I thought, well,
I'm going to have to go to a fertility
clinic, or what am I going to do?
And then eventually on youtube
there'll be a scientist.
So he'll have posted some sperm
under the microscope. So you know,
a little bit of trepidation,
put it in the,
and what came up was very
surprising and very helpful,
which is that a lot of young men seem to
like to make films of their sperm under
the microscope and post them onto
youtube and play a guitar solo with them.
So hurray for those men.
So yeah,
I got to write that passage with plenty
of input from youtube and it was,
it was great.
Oh,
timing is right.
I think you had other events going on
in your life that you worked on it for a
bit.
Put it aside.
Yeah.
And I think,
I think the reason it took my first
novel to first draft to six weeks,
and this one to first
draft took over a year.
And I think really the main difference
was that with my first level,
I had a lot of small children. So it
was that they look good, get it done,
I've got to get it done,
you know,
I'm really meant to be doing something
else here, got to get this done. And,
you know, I was able to take my time
with my second novel. And you know,
it's a luxury. It's a luxury
to take your time. That's good.
Shifting gears a bit,
we've talked a lot about the kindness
for the perfect lives. Kind of,
I found it very fascinating the
way you've structured the story.
It is not necessarily a linear kind
of plotline the characters, again,
weaving in and out of each other's lives.
For you,
kind of where did that idea
and inspiration come from it?
Um, it was, it was never planned. I,
nothing I ever write seems to be planned.
Everything takes on a life of its own and
with perfect lives. It really was that.
I wrote one story and then I wrote another
story. And what happened, for example,
the reason that the character's kept
emerging was they kept kind of a character
who was a minor character. And one
story I'd come to write the next room,
this catch me sticking their
hand up, me, me, me, right
about me. And so for example,
the first story I wrote
was called Barcarolle.
And there's about a piano tuner
who has terrible, he, he, he,
he was supposed to be a concert pianist
and then stage fright did for him.
And it's during his day is a piano tuner.
He meets a lot of pianos
and a lot of people.
So I'd written that story and then I knew
that the next story I wanted to write
was inspired by, um, on my
husband's last to the, on an island.
We went to Hamburg,
which is where my Jewish family were from.
And I was standing at the back of the
stage while the audience would sort of
screaming for an encore.
And I had a really unhealthy,
conflicted feeling. I had to
keep saying, it's not them,
it's not that there was something about
these people shouting that gave me the
chills. And I wanted to express that
secondhand memory thing. You know,
nothing happened to me,
but it happened to my ancestors
and they didn't do anything,
but maybe their ancestors did.
And it's,
it's a very difficult emotion.
Um,
and so I wanted to explore that.
And so I knew that I was going to have a
musician and I knew she was going to be
Jewish and I knew she was going to go
to Hamburg and she was going to play and
she was going to have those feelings.
And so I was thinking, well,
maybe I'll make her a pianist.
Yeah, okay. Oh, who is she?
And then I sort of thought back
to the story I've just written.
And then it's just a minor character in
there called who's piano was being tuned,
called a Raylea Lieberman. I thought
Lieberman, she's obviously Jewish.
And so that's really how
one emerges from another.
It's really not planned. And
then it gets to be fun. You know,
once you're a few stories in you, do
you start looking for them and thinking,
I'm going to tell your story.
It's great actually. It's really,
really a lovely form.
I think the link short story form,
I'm a huge fan of linked short stories
anyway. I mean, I love Elizabeth,
Elizabeth Strout, Olive Kitteridge,
and um, and I, and I love,
there's a book by Daniel Kelman could
fame, which is again, linked stories.
Wonderful. Yeah, it's a good form.
You touched upon a piano and piano tuner.
The Piano's seems to manifest itself in
almost every story you kind of, for you,
what does that symbolism as well?
I'm musical background that you want
to use that as the main motif for it?
Well, what happened was, um,
I had three sons and I wrote and then I
had a princess and I also knew she was
going to be my last baby.
So I,
I told myself I wasn't going to write
because of having this rather obsessive
personality, you know, writing kind of
blocks out children while I'm doing it.
And I thought I'm really going to just
enjoy my children and particularly my
last child not going to write,
I'm not going to write.
And a couple of my boys were learning
the piano and when they had to do their
piano practice,
you know,
like lots of boys that it didn't seem
to be anything you could do to persuade
them to sit down and do that practice.
And so I said to their piano teacher,
would it help if, if, if I learned
and then at least I could be helpful?
And she said, yeah, that, that, yeah, that
sounds like a good idea. But the thing is,
I am quite a geek.
So as soon as I started learning,
I kind of took it on and I, I a spending
sort of hours I could have been writing,
learning the piano. I mean, I was
playing the piano for five hours a day.
The children would come home and it's, I
need to do my piano practice. Sorry. Yeah,
I'm doing mine right now.
Took all the exams. I was like
a child prodigy, you know,
rose up through the, through
the levels. And yeah,
I kept kept on taking the exams, kept on
playing the piano, but it's not my thing.
And so when it came to the moment when
my daughter then went to nursery school
and I knew that it was time
to start writing again,
I was just absolutely soaked in piano
and piano became the metaphor for
everything. I wanted to
say. There's much to do
with learning a musical instrument.
Yeah, that's fascinating.
So I think this is a good segway
for kind of our next section.
We just talked about your musical,
um, piano training and whatnot.
So let's listen to a bit of a clip from
some of the lyrics and you've worked on,
and then we can discuss with
you, uh, your songwriting process
constantly.
So how did this collaboration
with your husband begin? Um, he,
he wasn't my husband at the time.
He was my boyfriend. Um, he was, um,
he had gone into a,
into a studio and he was
jamming with Rick, right.
Nick Mason for the first time,
I think since the 70s that
they'd played freely together.
I at the time had w what's in
England called glandular fever here,
I think it's called Epstein Barr.
So I was at home with a massively high
temperature and he'd come back in the
evenings and play me this
beautiful music and then say,
I just need a lyric. Um, I was working as
a journalist at the Sunday Times. Right.
Then I had no, I had, I had
no desire to be a lyricist,
but I was lying there with this fever.
I did occasionally sort of
see some obscure thing kind of
ivy growing over a door and he would
write it down and then it sort of,
these things would start sort of emerging.
And so it kind of,
he'd showed me something and he'd say,
I think this would work.
And I'd look at it once I'd taken
something to bring the fever down.
And I think not sure that does work quite,
yeah,
let me have a little fiddle with that.
And so it progressed and then
it became more formalized.
And at the beginning, um,
he said that, you know,
that he agreed that I wouldn't
have to have my name on it.
And I know that sounds odd, but
I, I don't know. It was, um,
it was a different world back
then. Yeah. You know, it was,
it was a misogynist culture,
particularly rock and roll, Pink Floyd.
I don't think it had
any female contributors.
I had this real sort of terror.
If my name was on it,
I would somehow people would start
calling me Yoko. Oh No. Yeah.
And I think about that now.
And I think what would be wrong with that?
I mean, she's an amazing
artist. She's an innovator.
She's never stopped.
She's incredible.
She's a woman in her eighties who still
producing new art. So I now think, please,
you know, if anyone would like to call
me Yoko Ono, I'll accept. But yeah,
with grace and enormous happiness.
Um,
but at the time that seemed like kind
of an insult. And so David said, okay,
it's fine. I'll pay you. And I
thought, Yay, but um, but you know,
your name doesn't need to be on it.
And then by the time we'd finished,
he sort of said, I'm sorry, but you
know, you're, you're getting a credit.
[inaudible] name's going on it and one
day you will thank me because you know,
uncredited work as a horrible feeling.
And he was right.
Because I'm really proud of that work.
And of course now I would,
I would really hate it
if my name wasn't on it,
but at the time who was a shrinking
violet. And again here, I know David,
I'll often mentions you're his muse
for you. Again, when you're writing,
is there a muse that's spurring on a
certain lyric one way or the other?
Or again,
is it just you're walking outside with
a tune and then she goes in the news is
the tune. And so I suppose the tune has
come from David. So you know, I mean,
and to know it sounds a bit happy couple
Lee, but I'd have to say that, you know,
the Muse for the lyrics,
it's quite clearly David,
because the music is always first
and yeah, you know, and it's a,
it's a wonderful thing to write a lyric
because you have this prompt, you know,
instead of that thing,
you know your stuff isn't it?
It's no blank page because it's there.
The music is there.
When I write a lyric,
he,
he scats a top line melody and the Scat,
it feels like it's just under the surface.
There are these words and it's just a
matter of sort of bringing them up to the
surface. You know, it's, it's,
it's a very different process from
writing something from what I think of as
scratch.
Yeah.
Is there ever an instance where the lyrics
came first and then the music later?
I think just, just once. And that
was on the last pink Floyd album.
Um, the endless river. And because
it was the end of the sort of,
it was put together from that
session I mentioned earlier,
there were so many beautiful pieces of
music and 10 or 11 of them made it onto
the division bell.
And for years we'd always been listening
to the other bits of music and they
were lovely. And so there came
a moment where it just felt,
but Bose pieces of music
should be released.
And Rick had sadly died.
And so I just felt awkward about imposing
lyric on something from a time when
Rick was alive. And so I didn't want
to write it to a piece of music,
but I knew that David wanted a song and
I knew that he wanted a song to be that
big full stop on the pink Floyd history.
So I wrote that song the louder than
words to sort of try and sum up the thing
to do that I'd noticed most
about the members of pink Floyd,
which is just how eloquently they speak
to each other with musical instruments.
But put them in a room together and it is
the most awkward thing you can imagine.
No one speaks. It's so, yeah. So
that's what that song's about.
It's about, it's about men who don't
use words to speak to each other,
but who had something else. Awesome. Yeah.
I think we're in listened to another clip
from the solo album, rattle that lock.
This one is called in tongue.
Let's get the AAV backup.
Just
it was hard way.
Has he done
so obviously some very strong war motifs,
the video itself as well.
Tell me a little bit about the process
behind this song and if it was any
different from what you just
mentioned. Yeah. Well this, this,
this was like in a way quite
a daunting song to write.
And it was the last one that
I wrote for rattle that lock.
And it was a piece of music that was so
suggestive of what it had to be about.
And I for some reason felt inhibited
by the enormity of that subject,
you know,
the wastage of war.
And so I spent a long time reading poetry,
basically what the poetry
of conscience. So, you know,
poetry written by people who'd
served in Afghanistan. Um,
a lot of different poetry. I mean, I
even read the poetry of the Taliban.
I wanted to sort of read a lot of poetry
to do with war and I kind of got really
bogged down in it and it got to the
point where I couldn't write a word.
And,
um,
and so I read more and more of these
collections of poetry and you know,
and in the end, David had,
look, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if it doesn't make
it onto the album, it doesn't matter.
You know, he's a very,
very good like that.
And I think it was kind of the
last day and I thought, oh,
that's such a great shoe.
I don't want to be responsible
for this not going on the album.
And I sat in the sunshine
and just thought, why am I
making such a meal at this?
I know what I think.
I know exactly what I think.
And I think I wrote the lyric and maybe
10 minutes once I'd given myself a from
talking to, yeah. Yeah. Uh, I think
we want to open it up to any audience,
Q and. A if you guys
have any questions. Uh,
now's a great time to ask polyon
everything she's talked about.
We have some mics
that'll be coming around.
Yeah.
When you write a short
story, you say, do you have
a path? The whole thing in your
head when you're doing a novel,
are you carrying the ending
Indian? And then he, I just
letting the story progress
and the characters develop.
You don't really know how you're going
to get to the ending and yeah. Um, what,
what um,
it's a great question because it is very
different from a short story writing a
novel and, and I think it's very different
for different sorts of novelists.
I have a friend who plots the whole
thing and I've quite envious really.
You go look in her writing room and
there it is, you know, chapter one,
chapter two and she knows everything
she's doing and it's just wonderful
scaffolding and she just hangs
the writing on the scaffolding.
But I have to admit that that would
bore me. I know who my characters are,
I know what their moral problems are.
I know the choice,
the moral choices they have to make.
But other than that,
I don't really know the ending and
things change. I mean this, this,
this method writing, that's
when things change. I mean,
walking as that person and thinking is
that person and responding to things as
that person makes the story and the,
and the,
and the journey to the end,
very different from something I might've
thought I was doing in the beginning.
And that's what makes it exciting
actually for me is it, you know, it, it,
I like the surprises.
I like the way that things I thought
I was going to do just change. It's,
it's, you know, it's endlessly
surprising. Yeah. Yeah.
We have another question in the back.
Hi. So I'm songwriting is something
that's always interested me, um, as,
and one of the things that's, uh,
I've always wondered is, you know,
after a certain point you
become famous, right? And, uh,
you're living a different
sort of, uh, of life than,
than other people and you're seeing
things that are different than other
people's and the average person.
Um,
and how do you still,
and yet often when artists become famous
there, their albums and not always,
but become better and better and
better. Okay. Sometimes worse,
but better and better there.
And I, I've always wondered,
how do you actually continue
to kind of be hungry,
continue to see things from the view
of non famous people who have a very
different potentially view of the world
that maybe you don't have any more
instill, connect, um, with, with people,
uh, that that's, uh, it's something I've,
I've just always wanted.
How does, how does,
how does pink Floyd or David or you get
down and still write a song today they
can connect with,
with us?
Well, thank you. Thank you.
I don't feel like I have a wall
anywhere built between me and anyone.
Um, I don't feel famous.
I mean, and I'm not. Um,
so I can't answer how it is to be
famous and, and, but I do know that,
you know, we live a very ordinary
life with, you know, we don't,
we live an ordinary life. Our
children go to school, we cook,
we, we walk, we walk our dog, our friends
and not famous people or friends or,
you know,
I feel very connected.
I don't feel my life has changed
because my husband is famous.
I thought answers the question
sort of.
I needed a sense of that.
It's not just fame, but it's,
it's a, you know, I, when,
when you first start writing, when you're
first writing songs, you're, you're,
you're just,
your financial position in your view of
the world and everything has got to be
very different than once you have weather.
Whether it's specifically you,
this famous, where that, that the
world that you're living, it's very,
very different world.
And I, I mean, I dunno,
like comfortably numb was written
about, you know, being on,
on tour or something like that. Something
like this, you know, uh, that's a,
that's something that most of us
don't. It's, it's a great song.
It's something most of us don't have.
I guess it's Kinda, how do you still,
how do you think you can
still connect to people?
One word answer to that and it's,
and it's the most important thing that
a writer needs to possess and it's
empathy. So, you know, it's
what I talked about. It's about,
it's like method writing,
you know,
it is about being able to get
under anyone's skin. And you know,
I don't think there's a writer alive
who hasn't got empathy as their greatest
skill. I mean, and if they
haven't, they shouldn't be writing.
Another question here.
So I'll preface this. I'm not a
published author, but I really a,
I understand your, your method, uh,
writing that you were discussing that
that's kind of exactly how I do stuff.
But when I do that,
I find that for every one finished
product that's like good and go somewhere
that's clever and you know,
other people might want to read it.
There's probably at least five to
nine other things that like, eh,
kind of petered out. It didn't work.
So you have two published novels now.
I was wondering how many did you start
writing that just didn't go anywhere?
Or are you able to salvage them somehow?
Um, you've got to silence your
inner critic because you know,
you say that an 800 line and not working,
but that's,
that's your inner critic
is telling you that.
And maybe your inner critic is being
too harsh with you. Just a thought.
Um, I don't have a load of stuff that
I've started and not, I tend to kind of,
if I start something,
I finish it,
but I take a long time to start something.
I have to know that the, you know,
it's going to take time,
it's going to take energy and
it's going to be obsessional.
So I have to know that I'm
jumping into the right pool. Um,
before I take the leap.
Um,
I've written one novel that
didn't reach full gestation.
It got to about 20,000 words and my
inner critic was deafening and actually I
found it on an old drive the other day
and my inner critic on that occasion was
correct. It was terrible.
But um, yeah, I think,
I think it's about
starting the right thing.
Um,
if that's any help.
That kind of segues to my next question
in terms of what's next for you and
other novel and other
short story collection. Um,
what's next for me is another novel.
Um,
I've got three novels kind of flow.
This is the thing about
selecting the right thing.
There are three ideas kind
of flying around out there
and it's which one to land.
No idea at the moment. And I can't
wait to just pick on, cause then,
then you again, you know, you can
get into that total obsession,
tunnel vision and think about nothing
but that research, nothing but that.
And that is the greatest state. Um, and
I also want to write some more lyrics,
but I can't do both things at once.
I need to have just one thing
in my head at a time. So
at this moment, I'm not
sure if it's lyrics next or
novel next. Yeah, we'll see.
And outside of writing, I know photography
is a big passion. What else drives you?
Well, photography's a big passion
because I'm not a natural photographer.
I'd say that because I've always written
on it is the thing. I, it's, you know,
for most of my life it has defined me
writing and photography doesn't come
naturally to me. So I love something
that I have to really work at and, and,
and I love learning.
And the piano is the same thing.
I like things that are incremental.
Yeah. Um, so, you know,
I've had all sorts of things,
but you know,
I can juggle and that again is a kind
of incremental learning thing and um,
yeah. And I still play the piano and
I play guitar. Yeah. Um, so yeah.
But my passion is writing.
Great. That's great. Uh,
there any other audience questions?
So we're gonna start off with
Pauli reading a little bit. Uh,
one short passage from the kindness.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm going to simply read the first
three pages just set in August,
1989 this bit,
although the novel spans 23 years,
Lucifer flew well for her in the fading
light falling through the sky when she
summoned him and to where again,
towards a great bruising sunset.
She was alone on the ridge at first,
just her the bird and the wide open view.
It was one of those nervy summer days of
southern strong winds that fretted the
hawks feathers as he stared at her
from his perch on her gauntlet.
She was wearing a long red
shirt over jeans and sandals.
Her hair was breaking free of its band.
A leather pouch hung from her belt and
a whistle from a cord around her neck.
The Hawk braced his feet on her wrist,
making a leather Tassel,
swinging from the gauntlet.
She felt the breadth of his feathers on
her face as he departed and she watched
him go with the wind win
right under his wings,
scattering crows like shock drops,
shaken from an umbrella.
Giulia was trying her best
to get it right for the bird.
The morsels were small to keep him active.
A shaming 26 ounces.
He'd weighed on the scales that morning.
She called him with a whistle too
sharp bursts, and there he was,
a dark cupid's bow firing
straight at her from the heavens.
She continued along the ridge.
Lucifer steady on her arm,
his manic eyes never leaving her
face until she gave the signal.
She sent him reeling to and fro and
neither of them knew that this was to be
their last dance. The
evening, started to chill,
had almost forgotten that Julian was
supposed to be meeting her there,
or perhaps she'd just given up hope.
He was panting when he arrived.
Still red in the face from the run up
the hill, his bike, and it's useless.
Tire abandoned.
He had the air of a boy who had
cross three continents to see her.
His sweatshirt knotted round his waist,
impossibly young with hair falling
over his eyes and an uncertain Lope.
One leg of his jeans still tucked
into a sock. He didn't dare Kisser,
he said with the Hawk glaring at him
like that. From the Ed end of her wrist,
the Hawk shrugged his shoulders and
she sent him flying. They kissed,
and when Julian stopped
glanced nervously at the sky,
she took off her going lit
and pushed his hand inside.
She urged the Hawk with her whistle
moving Julian's arm up and down,
the gauntlets tassel dancing,
but Lucifer only soared higher.
The wind whispering into
his ear and deafening him.
Him to her call Julia around
Cursing Julian lolloping beside her,
she grabbed back the Gordon at
and as the Hawk felter his kill.
Julian's hands were warm on her waist and
it seemed to them both that the scream
of the rabbit went on forever.
It was almost midnight when she got
back to which word she just stayed at
Julian's digs until morning if it
hadn't been for Lucifer bloody bird.
She parked the car in the lane, coaxed
him from his crate and clipped him on.
Lucifer shook out his feathers.
A little irked that somebody
had carelessly creased his cape.
Fallen twigs cracked underfoot
to she cut through the cops,
the bird or resentful weight on her arm.
The accurate Atri glitter of his eyes.
He only brightness beneath the trees.
The darkness dropped.
The branch is stilled,
which would stood alone in the clearing
as unexpected as a grims brother's
cottage with it's Wonky,
blackboards and crooked windows at once.
She could see a light was on there.
She was certain she'd switched
everything off her face.
Owlish white Giulia slipped through
the back gate whispering to Lucifer.
She transferred him to his post in the
shed and on a loan up the path heart
beating a skittering
stone loose at the steps.
She pushed the door open with her
foot and straight into the kitchen.
A gasp. Mostly relief. Chris, her husband,
streaky hair flat to his head.
His giant great trainers kicked
half way across the floor,
tinkering his spoon in a car.
She took half the pace back.
Why the look of surprise?
He said, I live here too.
You know Maggie has lurcher
quivered in disgust beside him.
Her nose pressed to his knee,
so here I am home.
He made a mockery of the
word bristling with it,
pointing his spoon at her like a weapon.
I wasn't expecting you.
She hung the leather gauntlets on its
hook brain racing for an alibi and
stalling. You gave me a fright.
You could have been anybody.
He cursed her for the welcome
bearing teeth older than his mouth.
Nescafe and tobacco. What did you do? Did
you leave Lucifer in the boot while you,
I couldn't get the car to start.
He snatched the leather pouch from her
and through the leftover bits of meat to
his dog. Then pulled it inside
out. If you don't clean it out,
there'll be maggots again. He was
supposed to be away until Christmas.
By which time Julia
promised herself to be gone.
His overalls fell open to a Ramones tee,
so faded you'd have to already know the
name of the band and down to a belt with
a large metal buckle.
He unloaded his pockets over the kitchen,
counter tobacco, Murray,
mints, Rolling Papers,
doped in change.
Clattering his hair was dotted
with gray paint like flies.
Have been laying eggs in it. It's
great. You're so pleased to see me.
He said a real treat.
Likewise.
I'll leave it there.
[inaudible]
all right. I think we will segue then
to the second reader. Perfect lives. Uh,
everybody join me in giving
a great round of applause.
[inaudible]
so, um, the thing to say
about this as I've, I've,
I've sort of taken a few
little bits of one story, um,
and talking about real life
influencing something you might write.
When I wrote this story or just before
I wrote it, I had three friends,
my three wonderful,
wonderful women who are married to really,
really boring men and these really
boring men left these wonderful women for
other women.
And these women who wouldn't,
who sort of would that seem to have
tired of these boring men all became
stalkers of the ex husbands and they
would all tell me about it and it was,
the material was just too good
to waste and um, you know,
the Internet makes stalkers of all of
us, so yeah. Anyway, it's called Morgana.
Yeah.
Morgana burst into my life jingling
and Jangling armfuls of bracelets and
puffing thin cigarettes
that she rolled herself.
Silk Flowers scattered here and there
in twists of dark hair fresh from her
crisis and still prone to sudden tears.
My shoulders were not the kind that
usually got cried on a bit on the tenant
side I suppose.
What would Simon working all the time
and Angus and Ivan like leaky buckets
never fall no matter how much I poured
into them. More Ghana's Fandango.
What a nightmare. Things being thrown.
Hot Cups of tea across the kitchen.
Mike's Clothes into marine parade.
The photographs of their wedding day
removed from the top of the piano put back
again twice and removed again with such
force that the glass shattered in the
frames.
She was wild when he left a river of
tears washing over a fortnight's dismal
blow jobs that fail to make him stay.
She put a brick through
the window at the basement.
He was renting one light when he
wouldn't open the door. His girlfriend,
Elizabeth, who he pretended it
didn't live there with him at all.
I looked up from playing her obo straight
at Morgana outside on the pavement and
laying the oboe carefully down,
raise to arms to release along
skein of hair from it's band,
sending it falling and swing down her
back like molten metal and sashayed to the
telephone to call the police.
Morgana is driving is not improved.
When she tells me about
these things I had,
they're not without misgiving
agreed to put my life in Morgana,
his hands a couple of afternoons a week.
She was quite bold when she suggested it.
Mike did all the driving.
She told me one afternoon when I'd
come with my films to the studio,
she ran from the basement of her house.
After 29 years in the passenger seat,
I'll be needing to brush up.
I never even got to touch the radio in
our car and the steering wheel was most
definitely out of bounds.
She said the first time she
sat clutching my car's wheel,
I'm sure I could drive.
I've definitely got a license and I can
remember taking a red mini moke right up
the middle of Portobello market.
I was in awe of her then I was nervous
when she developed my films and printed
my pictures worrying that my composition
was not good or the exposures ill
judged. She made prince for the best
of them. There was glamour to her.
She was for student with it.
All those bracelets she wore
the layers of fine fabrics,
the charms and old meaningful rings that
hung from her neck cluster together on
a long gold chain.
The hints of Rackety life once
lived up and down the kings road.
I called for her on Tuesdays and
Thursdays at two 30 in the afternoon,
so we had a clear out madame pedestrians
before I had to collect my leaky pair
of leaky buckets from their school.
Sometimes I could feel
my poor Persia quake,
a variety of stimuli could set Morgana
off and alabaster statuettes spike
through his window flaunting his
nakedness. A top is new desk.
Do you suppose it reminds him of her cds.
A book spotted lying on
the backseat of his car,
a thick one with an irritating title for
man on the cover looked to be in fear
of his life. She said, rattling my keys at
the ignition. Irritably what's he doing?
Reading self help books sometimes Morgana
told me she couldn't sleep at night
and in the darkness she
tip toed quite undetected,
sort of the perfumed gardens
of Elizabeth's Facebook.
Elizabeth seemed to have accepted Morgana.
His alter ego was a friend.
I said it just proved how few friends
she had in the real world bang outside
Mike's flat and into a space
either directly behind or
directly in front of his
car. Always seemed to be two Morgana to
be the perfect place to practice parking.
The code.
Curtains were drawn at the front.
They had been since the last time he'd
allowed her over the threshold and much
to Elizabeth's displeasure and more.
Ghana's later mortification.
She and Mike had ended up wrestling
on the floor like bad children.
Once parked,
Morgana was able to nip out and search
for those little sharp nuggets of
information that she so craved. Peering
through the windows of his black Audi.
I watched her with her hands against the
glass of the car that had once been her
chariot and cringed as I
imagined Elizabeth or Mike
seeing her there awaken the
giant within.
What's that supposed to mean?
When did he ever read books like that?
She huffed as we pulled away in a
series of ostrich jerks. Mirrors,
mirrors. I yelled, city little girl
must be telling him what to read.
Self help her bracelets. Jangled as she
thumped the steering wheel for emphasis.
He never had any trouble helping himself.
Ignoring the hooting from the car behind.
What do you suppose I did to his giant?
Any way to put it to sleep. She scraped
the gears as she changed into third.
Sorry. She said to me and to the man
who'd overtaken shaking his head and he's
listening to the 10 things. What was he
doing? Listening to the team meetings.
Thanks again, everybody. Okay.